Once upon a time, it was rare to see a character
straight-up return from the dead.
Existing in narrative limbo under a shroud
of post-story ambiguity, like what happened
to Breaking Bad's Walter White or Tony Soprano
in The Sopranos?
Sure.
But to come entirely back?
That was highly unlikely.
It was even less likely in action films like
the Fast and the Furious franchise, which
don't necessarily lend themselves to the same
high-concept, rule-bending universe-building
of science-fiction, fantasy, and superhero
genres.
And yet, the first trailer for the ninth Fast
and Furious movie, F9, teased just that.
The final few seconds of the trailer effectively
rose fan-favorite character Han from the grave.
Han made his first appearance in the Fast
franchise in 2006's The Fast and the Furious:
Tokyo Drift, the same film in which he was
believed to have died in a fiery car crash.
In the F9 trailer, he's seen walking through
a corridor, snack in hand as always, and then
there's this:
"Nice clubhouse."
Whoa!
That's unexpected.
The big reveal has many fans excited — and
it should, because Han's return to the Fast
and Furious film series is due in large part
to them.
In a recent interview with Entertainment Weekly,
F9 director Justin Lin explained that after
he departed from the Fast franchise back in
2013, a new story idea coupled with comments
from hardcore fans inspired him to come back,
bringing his long-time collaborator and Han
actor Sung Kang with him.
He told EW,
"I would travel and just meet people and fans
of the franchise, and they would tell me why
they love the franchise so much and just share
their stories.
And along the way, I hadn't seen the other
two movies, and I was at a Q&A for Better
Luck Tomorrow and someone brought up 'justice
for Han,' and so all these things were kind
of working together."
The #JusticeforHan hashtag was started by
fans angry over the franchise's decision to
turn former Fast and Furious villain Deckard
Shaw into an ally of Dom Torretto's crew before
then giving him and Lucas Hobbs a 2019 spin-off.
In the sixth Fast installment, Shaw was revealed
to be behind Han's presumed death in Tokyo
Drift.
Oddly enough, Han's F9 appearance will basically
serve as his second resurrection.
In a 2016 interview with EW celebrating the
10th anniversary of Tokyo Drift, both Lin
and actor Sung Kang said the story of the
nomadic, silent observer with deep pockets
actually goes all the way back to the director's
first feature film.
In Fast Five, it's established that the name
"Han Seoul-Oh", with "Seoul" spelled like
the capital of South Korea, is an alias — and
an obvious reference to Han Solo from Star
Wars.
Lin subsequently confirmed in various interviews
that Han is actually a continuation of Han
Lue, the chain-smoking partier with a moral
compass from his 2002 independent crime drama
Better Luck Tomorrow.
Based on the real-life 1992 "honor roll slaying,"
the film follows a group of high-achieving
Asian American high school students who swap
suburban boredom for a school-wide cheating
operation that takes a dark turn.
Lin and Kang have grown alongside this character
— which is why when the director departed
from the franchise, it felt right to finally
let the character go.
But now Lin is saying that both he and Han
have unfinished business in the flashy Fast
and Furious universe.
He told EW in January 2020,
"When I left, I felt it was appropriate, and
I felt like we were putting the character
to bed, but it's because of some of the things
that happened that didn't quite make sense
to me, and so I felt like if I was going to
come back, I really wanted to explore why."
It's still unclear how, exactly, Han will
make his return, but we'll know soon enough.
F9 races into theaters on May 22.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.